savez-vous tellement vite première
sélection est là maintenant on dit après
trois coupe d'afrique après peut-être
première coupe du monde ce sont des
idées qui nous trotte dans l'esprit en
1998 à l'âge de deux ans assia sidhoum
et ses parents quittent l'algérie pour
le québec
iman chez bell elle est née au québec de
parents algériens arrivés en 1990
rapidement les deux jeunes filles vont
se découvrir une réelle passion pour le
soccer jusqu'à devenir des joueurs
semi-professionnels assia étudiante en
communication à l'uqam
babin joué durant deux ans dans la n 6
et et le prestigieux circuit américain
les stingers de concordia eux peuvent
compter sur les talents de défenseur du
man étudiants en biochimie
il ya un an le téléphone sonne et à
l'autre bout c'est le sélectionneur de
l'équipe nationale d'algérie qui les
invite à faire partie du onze national
sahraoui depuis longtemps j'étais
vraiment excité j'avais hâte c'est sûr
que j'ai très fier et javert de partager
la nouvelle avec ma femme et mes parents
ont représenté un pays puis
si on fait bien ben là les gens y vont
plus nocifs puis ça va ça va peut-être
entrer dans la mentalité des gens dans
caire on a un peu une pression des de
bien faire justement pour que les choses
évoluent pour les deux joueuses
en plus de la fierté de représenter le
pays d'origine de leurs parents si aussi
d'être un modèle pour que le sport
féminin prennent de plus en plus de
place et que les mentalités évoluent
wallis oiseaux et sous un soleil squale
fatima avoir le même accès au sport le
même support mais que ce soit financier
ou autre mais je crois que dans leurs
années de ça quand même beaucoup évolué
et on entend beaucoup plus parler du
foot féminin
sa scène internationale donc je vais
dire c'est sûr quand on avance donc
françois réjouir mais ya encore du
travail à faire même si leur idole
incontesté et l'ancien capitaine de
l'équipe de france d'origine algérienne
zinedine zidane acia et iman était
nerveuse à l'idée de rencontrer de
nouveaux joueurs de l'impact de montréal
saphir taïder qui évolue lui aussi avec
l'équipe nationale d'algérie recentrer
tard
[Applaudissements]
l'état je trouve que c'est une bonne
chose voilà l'histoire est ouvert à tout
le monde le fait aussi d'avoir des
équipes nationales féminines c'est ça
montre que la fédération algérienne
travaille bien et que ça pousse aussi ce
sont les jeunes filles à faire du sport
à jouer au foot savoir que le foot
rassemble beaucoup de personnes un
collectif donc forcément beaucoup de
sourires et c'est ce qui fait c'est ce
qui fait la différence pour doit unir
les personnels et non pas les écarter
assia elle aussi est consciente que le
sport peut être un formidable outil
d'émancipation pour les femmes qui n'ont
pas toujours la possibilité de le
pratiquer sans que des fautes ça offre
ça ouvre à beaucoup d'opportunités se
veut un voyage et de jouer dans des
commandes au pays donc on peut lire dans
les yeux de acia et dimane toute la
fierté de représenter le pays d'origine
de leurs parents on retrouve la même
étincelle chez l'international algérien
saphir taïder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'abord c'est une fierté voilà parce
qu'on présente pas seulement un drapeau
un maillot mais mais beaucoup de gens un
peuple voilà moi chaque fois que je
porte le maillot c'est une fierté un
honneur parce que beaucoup de gens
aimeraient être à notre place donc
forcément c'est ces voix là c'est
beaucoup de joie de bonheur des moments
intenses au mois de juin
assia iman vont disputer leur match
décisif contre les éthiopiennes une
victoire leur ouvrirait les portes de la
prestigieuse coupe d'afrique des nations
ce serait un bel exemple pour les hommes
qui n'ont pas réussi à se qualifier pour
la coupe du monde
mais comme le dit si bien saphir taïder
quelle que soit la victoire ce sera
celle de tout un peuple
c'est robert frosi radio canada montréal
[Applaudissements]